how long is a piece of string the  age-old question well according to the  ancient Greeks that would depend on your  destiny the three sisters known as the  Mori or more commonly the fates were the  goddesses of Fate they tirelessly spun  the threads of human Destiny the  youngest clother would be the first to  begin spinning as she decided the moment  we were born the next sister lacassist  spun the threads representing every  event and action taken in our lives the  elder sister atropus would cut the  thread with a pair of scissors when our  time had come to an end the fates were  responsible for ensuring every human was  living the destiny intended for them so  to answer the question how long is a  piece of string hopefully very long